[Music]
round eight of the norm Congress here in
st. Louis International Master Sergei
met cinco clinched victory in the IM
norm section the top-rated russian
simultaneously crushed josiah Stearmans
goal of a norm in the stronger field the
ukrainian grandmaster Vorontsov and the
Greek solo Kido won their games norms
are within reach but only if stavroula
and josh colas win these last games
final round coverage starts now players
all over the world have struggled to
earn the Grandmaster title which players
will earn a norm which players will go
home with the prize welcome to the 2018
st. Louis norm Congress
hello chess fans and welcome to the
final day coverage for the 2018 norm
Congress here in st. Louis I'm Ben Simon
along with Grandmaster Josh Frieda and
despite what that intro just told you
Josh Colossus is no longer eligible for
North that's right he lost his game to
Brandon Jacobson tough loss he got kind
of an equal ascending but took a couple
too many risks and went down he's still
at least guaranteed a share of second
place at least but his norm chances are
- the good news room is he already had
to do I am norms and a GM norm I don't
think he'll be too disappointed indeed
it's all about the performance let's
take a look at the Grandmaster norm
standings after yesterday going into the
final round
Pablo Vorontsov leading with five and a
half he looks to be winning up upon
against Akshar andra still some work to
do
Patel is in a tough battle and so lucky
who is black against Ottawa Borromean I
like tapas position and that might - the
rulers chances for a norm but as we've
seen in these games anything can really
happen a lot of these games are still up
in there and please keep in mind that
there are no playoffs at the end of
today if there are players tied for
first they're tied for first they'll
split the money and let's take a look at
the international master norm standings
after around 8:00 going in to the final
round
indeed Saturday Mott Sanko as you can
see clinched the tournament already Josh
colas already lost to brendham Jacobson
who goes up to three and a half not the
best scorer for him however considering
he started out oh and three I'm sure
he'll be happy with how he finished the
tournament indeed and all the important
points of this field have been finished
up we have the winner there are no norms
in this section but today right now live
you're watching it on us chess champs
calm hopefully let's take a look at the
pairings for this round in the top
section yeah as always we're keeping a
real close eye on that game between Tata
Abraham yeah
and stop ruler so lucky do interesting
game lots of back and forth and it's
vital first of rulers norm chance so
she's got to win with the black pieces
and otherwise we're looking at verone's
up against chandra of course playing for
first place if Veronica wins he takes
the matters into his own hands he
clinches first regardless of what
happens but he still has stuff ruler and
he Elsa has a deep Attell against hammer
cool of a fatty Patel wins he passes
bronze of temporarily meaning that the
Iran sub would have to win to clinch
first and a draw with only time for
first for sure alright and let's take a
look at the International Master dorm
pairings this round these games are
going on right now and like we said the
field the important parts have been
wrapped up but there are still some good
games going here indeed Josh Cole has
already lost as we mentioned against
Brandon Jacobson otherwise we still have
Mott Sankoh playing against Justin wing
mots angle up a palm but hasn't quite
reeled in the point yet Justin defending
pretty well and otherwise we have a few
interesting games still going so we'll
probably bounce around maybe take a look
at some of the other games as they
finish and this tournament format yeah
the round started three hours ago so
that's why the games are wrapping up the
time control is game in 90 minutes with
a thirty second increment from move one
and as stated before there are no
playoffs there will be a tie for first
if players are in the in the lead after
this round okay Josh let's take a look
around the horn and see what's going on
yeah so I guess first I'll show what
happened to Josh it was in this position
this was one of our games of the day
before it ended and as you can see it's
about equal I would say Josh had this
pawn on e5 is a little weak but this
night on g5 is a great piece it attacks
both of these two pawns no doubt the
rook is the rooks are also perfect and
honestly what you should do in a
position like this you can't really
improve too much but you can sit play
moves like rookie seven maybe be six
just kind of see what White's up to I
don't think I can do much of anything
here if you really want to you can move
your knight back and forth if you want
to be able
about it but really there's not much to
improve and I think that the problem is
when you really want to win and you
always are trying to improve your pieces
sometimes you actually make them worse
and after Josh maneuvered his night this
night looks nice but the problem is it
only attacks one point whereas the night
on g5 attacked two and I feel like it
was a bit more active there and sure
enough Brandon was able to double note
how this would not be possible if the f3
palm are under attack and then he starts
rolling and maybe Josh is doing okay
here but it becomes much tougher to play
Brandon plays aggressively and as you
can see this knight is in some bad shape
here if captures captures you threaten
the fork which is quite nasty as well as
we're coming in so rook f7 rook a 1 a 4
again it looks like both sides have
protected passers but these pawns
restrict black's knight and that's gonna
really decide things here and as we can
see Brandon comes in this Knight now
threatens to go to d5 another nice
maneuver threatening to go to d4 hitting
this King now white could actually play
Knight d4 check here I thought he would
and just grabbed the exchange I thought
this would be fairly easily winning
because if the King moves back you can
take this with check I thought that was
over but he chose something else which
was pretty good and from here on Josh
was just up against it he fought on he
tried to make counter play with his a
pawn but he simply corralled it moat how
this Knight just has no escape squares
he tried this and white doesn't even
bother taking he just takes this pawn
there's the pin if 97 you could probably
win by just taking the rook but even
this one is even nastier the idea being
that if takes rook pawn takes Knight
this guy Queens so a tough end of the
tournament for Josh but he still has to
be happy with it as a result he gave
lots of rating he did well he was one of
the lowest rated players in the event
but it's a sad way to end a tournament
where is for Brenham Jacobson who had a
rough tournament he ends on a high note
he can go home at least moderately happy
right yeah that's that's one point we
should not ignore
Brandon Jacobsen yeah it has been a
tough run this just go around indeed
other results
I should mention Daniel Gurevich against
John Bartholomew
kind of an interesting opening but got
to this kind of tame position the
bishops are okay they cover all the
weaknesses but there's not really much
to do so both sides decided to call it a
tournament call it a day
understandable from both parties we
might actually talk to John later
hopefully and we'll get to meet him very
interesting guy very nice guy so I look
forward to that and otherwise mark Parag
wa won his game against Danish Boros who
finishes in last place and he might tie
for last but it's a pretty a pretty
rough showing for him he really had a
tough time at the end and Mark Parag WA
bounces back from a tough loss to the
Sevilla yesterday as you can see in this
position he's only down one palm but
after say I move like Queenie 7 this
Knights hit f5 is threatened and if the
knight moves rook d8 maybe he could have
found a way to play on a little bit more
but it was a pretty rough position and
he decided simply to call it a day why
don't we move into our other game of the
day which was stuff Rula as black
against Tottenham as whites so as you
can see
Tata pushed her King side pawns nothing
abnormal there and keep in mind that
black actually likes a kind of double
edged game because blacks trying to win
this in order to get a GM norm however I
think this position is likely just very
very bad for black this King is
certainly more open than whites this
bishops probably going to come here
hitting this pawn it seems like white is
just doing quite well it's not a
material at the moment but it seems like
blacks a bit paralyzed and black is not
doing so well but it turns out we
actually have a guest in the studio as I
mentioned John Bartholomew drew his game
so why don't we go to that and welcome
John hey Josh how's it going pretty good
good to see you
yeah been a while yeah we grew up
playing together so we've played a
number of times if I recall correctly
you were I I didn't beat you too many
times yeah I recall watching one of the
earlier broadcasts yeah this tournament
and you were talking about how known
each other for a while yeah yeah you are
a blight on my mega database statistics
because I don't know if you remember
this game but I played b3 against you on
move like
this game you absolutely crush me yes
otherwise it's just tea it's very tough
to beat and it seems like you had kind
of a back and forth tournament ended
okay how would you how did you feel
about it yeah overall I feel pretty good
finished plus one mm-hmm I lost in the
first round against Shamrock Yadav in a
position that I probably should have
drawn yeah
Bishop bending was same same amount of
bonds oh yeah and that really puts a
damper I found on these nine round
tournaments when you have an early loss
like that because you don't have hardly
any margin for error after that so I did
manage to string together some wins a
lot of crazy games I mean I had this
game against advi-- Patel yesterday that
was just back and forth you know I think
a draw was a fair result in that 100
just blundered a rook against me I was
looking I'm like this I think it's an
x-ray what's going on with the rook on
f7 that was have you received a blunder
like that before no never and ever I was
talking about on my Twitter yeah I just
I I was so confused and it was a case of
almost mutual blindness I didn't see it
for about two minutes I but I spent like
two and a half minutes on that move yeah
and it took me about two minutes before
I recognized that King takes f7 as
possible so sometimes it's just when
when one side blunder is especially
between two really strong players
there's a certain level of trust and I
think that you know when someone makes a
horrible blunder sometimes it takes that
minute because you're like wait they
couldn't upon the rookie chasuble know
GM is gonna hang a rope but I hate to
break it to you guys gyms do it Kings
work occasionally um so what why don't
you take us through your current game
any interesting points you want to note
it looks like the final position like as
the bishops but no we're weaknesses for
either side kind of tough to make
progress where the rain chances earlier
for either of you um I didn't notice any
huge chances for white
Daniel garbage has been a tough opponent
for me and I was having a rough event
but I think I have half out of three
against who what I find difficult and
playing against him is he plays
extremely fast I think virtually every
game he's he's up on the clock no matter
who he's playing so he's he's tough if
you get in time pressure against him so
I was resolving to move quicker and I
was still like 20 minutes behind on the
clock in the final position yes one of
the reasons I offer to draw but okay I
think on move number nine
yeah this this opening was actually a
little I haven't quite seen this way to
playing before so yeah age six so I had
a game earlier in the tournament if you
back up a couple moves before I played
at four yeah so actually I played f3
against me here so I've had this
position and I wasn't expecting Daniel
to play into this line so I was
expecting some sort of preparation after
f4 I've had a couple recent games one
with Bishop e7 one with b5 the cultural
variation you're just absolutely insane
yeah I think the nickname is actually
the cultural suicide variation yeah you
can get a you can get a feeling for what
that line play in your own race there's
some Queenie one move or something yeah
try to recall I haven't played it for a
little while but so there's a lot of
variations that black is hanging on by a
thread but the positions are a lot of
fun so you chose h6 g5 it certainly is
yeah and I played this before against
Sam smiegel okay a few months ago and I
figured Daniel might not be expecting
this yes I mean I'd imagine if you're
not prepared for a move like this it's
quite something so after takes 94 Knight
f3 this is all normal right Bishop e3 a
7 is it possible to play a move like g6
here or trying to sac something or just
nothing quite work I don't think so yeah
I don't think it works out tactically
yeah it was just curious because I was
glancing very quickly I'm like I don't
know maybe but alright not after he
drops his bishop back to g3 ah he was
thinking for a little while after H
takes g5 maybe contemplating whether he
can take on d6 but I think after the
swap then Knight f2 and I don't believe
White's attack is gonna work out like
something like 95 should not work yeah
it seems like the problem is that
White's Knights just don't have that
they're happy squares like if I could
take advantage of these be tough but a
move like 95 I assume you have to take
it right pawn takes or yeah Ponte
there's no like if rook e1 you can maybe
even just take or push or something to
eat everything basically
and if pon takes you just take the rook
right yeah yeah I think rook takes is
good and I was looking at can he move
his bishop here and try to quickly get
his ripped in one but it looks very
doubtful and it seems one key thing is
after pawn takes Knight you can capture
because of Queen e5 check you can run
king g7 and Queen defends the rook yeah
nothing's crucial so yeah
nothing quite working so he just played
Bishop e2 right you put your knight on
e5 and that's kind of the whole point of
this variation as I'm sure you're well
aware get the Knight to e5
very nice square black has a good
structure for a Sicilian you know but
some weaknesses at the same time yeah I
mean it's always kind of position you
know it's never quite been my style to
have to do with this many weaknesses but
the positions look fun like you know
they they're interesting to play you
have to be careful f-7s often weak but
it's also difficult cuz as you can see
this Knight doesn't really have squares
it doesn't seem like it's that easy to
play for either side so black played
Queen a5 mhm
King b1 f6 yep showing things up in the
center mm-hmm Bishop d3 so it seems like
neither of you is really up to too much
here but I feel like if White's not
doing much to prove anything you should
be pretty solid yeah that's why I found
in these positions once the play settles
down and certainly if you're able to
trade Queens as in a lot of Sicilians
that end games are just great for black
mm-hmm yeah and often the the weakness
and in a structure like this is this
pawn but white needs a way to attack it
usually in kind of classical Sicilian
structures white tries to get out the
Bishop to g4 or h3 or some way to attack
this pawn if this bishop were here it
might be a totally different position
but it seems like just as it is this is
just too hard to attack so again my my
feeling would be here you're doing well
here but yeah but at the same time how
do you make progress right exactly you
know I'm proposing a queen trade here he
has some chances on this diagonal
leaning towards a7 mm-hmm getting his
Queen and his Bishop lined up uh-huh but
otherwise I felt pretty good about the
position I was just burning some time
here trying to find the best order of
moves in so you do allow Bishop f2 but
I'm guessing none of it works I guess
you be three hangs here right exactly so
if Bishop d3 if you have to you can just
do this and there's no I guess there's
this move but I'd imagine even sacking
the exchange is quite viable yeah right
yeah it's bishop or rook takes you have
two pawns this looks very nice for you
yes
structure but I guess you always have to
watch out for these kind of things so
right b3 Queen back Queen e3 so you were
trying to be subtle with Bishop f2 I
suppose yeah and I was thinking about
the best way to deal with this and I
just decided to play King 8 and Queen b8
so it's not to weaken my structure if I
have to play b5 somewhere to guard a7 I
feel like that's when things can go
wrong for you yeah cuz your general
feeling is you already have weaknesses
you
right it more that makes I want to throw
the queenside in the banks so the Queen
um PA looks a little passive but at the
same time how do you how do you take
advantage right because white doesn't
have any pawn breaks so they're
essentially relying on peace activity
yeah probing so a3 and somehow things
just kind of petered out for you guys
ah Queen B eights so yeah he could trick
maybe try to go for something more
ambitious than 92 I didn't see any
particularly good plans you know h3 we
could start with and then prepare Bishop
f2 so he doesn't run into Knight g4
mm-hmm so a move like Age 3 but you can
still probably play queen a7 nice soon
oh no yeah I was also thinking about
maybe rook c7 and double the rooks I
looked pretty reasonable c7 and it's a
little unclear what both sides should go
for because the play in the center and
the king side is amounting to much for
either side I think it's a standoff on
the Queen side it's probably pretty
equal yeah it's a pretty tough position
because if you ever taking the bishop is
always just blacks very happy opens up
the pieces the double pawns are nothing
d4 always runs in 294 mm-hmm so there's
just not a lot for either side to do the
bishops you think would give black an
edge in some positions but honestly this
Bishop is hard activates yeah so you
guys played a few more moves but decided
to so he did play d4 okay you can play
d4 and I guess technically you don't
have to move this Knight but I suppose
there's no there's no reason not right
yep so in 94 you trade yeah I mean this
looks just very Josh yep
and you guys decided to call it a so
solid game to finish the tournament
looking plus-one pretty solid result in
the tough field where do you play next
so I'm playing in two more days at the
Southwest class Championships in Dallas
so I fly back home to Minnesota and one
day off and then another tournament
immediately awesome fine tuner or like
that's that's pretty intense do you find
that you tend to play do you like having
the tournament before so that's the
second tournament you are warmed up or
do you feel like you're not as fresh or
is it just a trade off that's a good
question because I definitely done both
but in the past several months I've
committed to playing more trying to
eventually make the Grandmaster title if
I can yeah and I found that for me the
best thing is just to play as actively
as possible I mean every time I make
progress it's because of playing and not
so much studying I found okay so I don't
mind playing back-to-back
because once I get in chest mode I feel
pretty good and if I have a good
tournament I want to play even more ah
so it's it's almost just a numbers thing
you feel like just you play lots of
tournaments eventually you'll get a good
you'll get there and how many rooms you
have so far I've won one yeah and I've
come close recently I played a
tournament in Charlotte at the Charlotte
chefs Center last month and I needed to
beat David broadsky in the final round
talented I am and I would have made a
norm if I did that yeah and came up just
short and we drew the game also I played
a tournament in Norway in October that
is very good and it was close to making
a norm there so I feel like I'm knocking
on the door but I just need to get more
games I'm here right there but and your
ratings about twenty 450 it's gone up a
little bit so after this tournament
robably 24 75 75 so it seems like you're
almost in prime position you get that
last norm you might cross 25 and you're
done so very close and it seems like if
you play a lot and it's just a matter of
time till you happy yeah because that's
what I've noticed for most everyone
who's making the push from I am to GN if
you go look at their results in the feed
a webpage then you know they have a
string of tournaments and they're active
like every single month every supplement
playing 918 games and yeah actually good
things happen eventually something good
can happen of course you can lose a lot
of rating if you have a bad patch but
yeah it seems like that's kind of the
way to go about it so the other thing
you have a YouTube channel that's right
so I haven't actually watched it I have
to admit you know advertised it for me
like what goes out to my youtube
subscribers it's funny because in these
tournaments that are broadcast online
you can go and watch on the chess 24
page or in the app and there's all these
comments like talking about my game in
particular and I always think it must be
weird for my opponents in these
tournaments to go to the go to the the
broadcast site and see like this random
I am from the US like getting all these
comments like why does he have such a
cute boys
but yeah it's cuz of my youtube channel
which has about 50,000 subscribers
posting videos for over three three
years now I have over 1,300 videos up
there you're prolific I'm trying I mean
I love chess this is my my lifelong
passion and my livelihood as well and
yeah I started the channel just as
mainly a way to practice because I
wasn't playing a lot on my own I was
teaching a lot but I wasn't forcing
myself to play and it's kind of turned
into something that I also get to share
my love for the game with people which
is
so it kind of works out and yeah I mean
to have that many followers you must be
doing a lot of good stuff so it's good
to hear anything you'd like that no I
just I'm very glad to be playing in st.
Louis I mean these tournaments are top
here before yeah I played one of these
events in October November and yeah it's
just fantastic as an IM to be able to
play a tournament where you have a very
good chance of recouping all your
expenses or even coming out in the black
yeah like that that's amazing I mean
that doesn't happen is I'm not not at no
tournaments as we've discussed earlier
in the show it's like an ornament
sometimes you have to pay big entry fees
just to play it's a big pain whereas
here you get really nice conditions and
your your money it's a pretty big deal
yeah yeah plus playing at the club is
just it's a nice place to uh yeah it's
great I mean if you guys haven't been to
the club and you're a chess fan like
definitely put this on your bucket list
to come here because it's awesome yeah
anyway I think we're gonna get back to
the games but yeah thanks for thanks for
coming on and good luck in your next one
yeah thanks Josh I'm very curious to see
how step rule is gonna do against taught
to us yeah it looks like quite a game
yeah alright we're gonna take a short
break and we'll be right back
a question on Twitter from dem s I
should not have pronounced that there
was a bit of a champion for those of you
who are new to chess it might look like
ba 3 is an illegal move here because
white advances pawn to square is not 1
but it still is something we call hustle
and you can do that but you have to do
it instantly you can't wait for a move I
plants a claim King in seven Kim G - and
now try because all played four against
Lawrence and now he's going to play
something against me which we discussed
at length during the course of my steak
yeah he told me this is that d5 this was
what I was kind of hoping for because
now I think the farthest I know who
Lawrence this is not how it works
certainly would be much much more fun if
chess actually work like this I don't
think it does well maybe it does well
that's me regretting what I just said
how did I get from there to here is a
little bit beyond me
and what's worse I will never hear the
end of my quality of life has just gone
downhill tremendously because I'm
actually sharing the office of the guy
[Music]
[Music]
there's a weekend vacation in a nearby
city I'm Mike Metheny whether you play
chess for fun or want to boost your
child's academic performance come visit
the Chess Club and scholastic Center of
st. Louis right here in the chess
capital of the u.s. from a welcoming
diverse environment to a Scholastic
outreach program now in over 100 schools
our Center across from the world chess
Hall of Fame the Central West End has it
all so whether you've played for years
or never before we invite you to
experience all chess has to offer
and we're back with the final round of
the 2018 st. Louis norm Congress Ben
Simon along with Grand Master Josh Reed
L here for the call and that was a great
interview with Josh John Bartholomew
yeah not surprising John's a well-spoken
guy has his YouTube channel he's used to
talking on air his the the crisp voice
you know he's just always a good person
to talk to in a good interview not
surprising he didn't ask her the big
question Josh what is the secret to
getting fifty thousand subscribers on
YouTube I didn't think you'd give that
away Ben it's not like you get fifty
thousand are like by the way here's that
I did probably he does lots of videos
and does lots of work so there's your
answer folks at home and by the way the
st. Louis Chess Club YouTube channel
where you might be watching this stream
right now this isn't too shabby itself
give it a subscribe now and thanks for
checking us out here on us chess champs
comm why don't we look at some games
definitely the one of the games we want
to look into is this game one of the
games of the day between stavroula and
Tata Tata
Abraham Yan is white against the rule of
kudu and it's unsurprising to most of us
a crazy game this is this is quite
something why don't we show a little bit
how this happened in the opening it was
a night off as we see and taught the
place to move tough that's a big fan of
English attack she usually plays Bishop
III ef3 is kind of her normal system but
here she diverts and plays 93 not sir
she's played this before but it's a
little bit of a weird-looking move I
wouldn't want to have to describe this
move to my students withdrawing a piece
from the center rather than developing
or preparing to develop another piece
but the idea is simply that it's a
little bit flexible it waits for black
to commit and now when black plays these
six BAM g4 oftentimes you have to play
h3 to support this move and h3 sometimes
end up being a waste so it's nice be
able to get this in in one move and
often the knight has to withdraw from
the center eventually anyway
so taut that just keeps pushing and the
idea is that when you form this pawn
wedge it makes it harder to attack any
one pawn it's possible to play 8 v h6
sometimes and also it stays flexible
sometimes the bishop likes to be here to
guard the square other times it can come
out to h3 to put pressure on e6 lots of
different ideas so they played here this
all looked fairly logical a3 is a mixed
move because after before you open up
the Queen side and considering the
King's gonna end up cancelling there
it's a little risky however if you allow
b4 in this position this Knight just has
no we're good to go
so it's that ends up being more
important here probably
stavroula plays rook b8 logical looking
move she's looking at night c4 when
captive simply allows it this move
surprised me I thought she might just
play Knight d4 right away with the idea
being that if Knight takes Queen takes
maybe even Bishop takes but the idea is
this pawn is under attack sometimes it's
actually a little annoying to do with it
with h5 h6 coming in she opted for h5
and here there was a huge branch black
could've blackened the game castled
which looks scary to me but as you can
tell these ladies do not have much fear
I certainly would but at the same time
it's hard to come up with lots of great
moves 94 is possible you don't really
want to give up your bishop or allow
this so you would take it and play here
and stuff ruler could have grabbed this
pawn but it looks a little risky after
takes takes maybe Bishop d4 hitting this
pawn this Knight threatens to move with
a temple on this rook maybe it's not so
simple
castles Queen side is even a possibility
in some positions I honestly have no
idea what's going on here I think it's a
complete mess another possibility was
maybe trying h6 which is a common
response to this h5 move when the rook
is still here the idea being that after
a move like g6 sometimes you can even
play this you get a nice active Bishop
and there's no after pawn takes
sometimes even King takes and the idea
is that there's just no way to get at
this King so easily and in the meantime
White's got black has a very active
Bishop and it often works as nice
compensation which I'm going to swing
the rook over now sometimes yes you
swing the rook over and then you can
even artificially castle it depends
whether the Kings really better on G
or not that can vary sometimes
occasionally you the king has to run the
other way if it gets too scary
but it's actually not as bad as it looks
and this Bishop on f6 is just a really
nice piece so this was maybe something I
would have considered but I'm more
safety minded than a lot of players so
black Council which probably isn't that
horrible either lots of commits to h6 a
committal move and it looks strange to
close the Queen's up they can't close
the Kings side like this if that's where
you're gonna be attacking but the idea
is this square is actually a very
annoying there are times when black
white plays a queen to d4 and believe it
or not you have no good way to stop that
mate you have to weaken yourself really
severely so this is just a long-term
problem for black however it doesn't
mean the king stays safer for the time
being she does play Knight d4 this
nighttime b3 was no longer useful and
again she wants that Queen coming black
plays rook to e8 thoughts of castles and
here the game kind of gets nuts she
plays Bishop f8 they trade and thought
that plays f5 again I thought she might
opt for Queen d4 maybe with Queen f6
ideas I thought you might just develop a
piece I really wasn't sure but she
decided you know what I'm gonna open
things it's possible for black to take
this pawn but it's always a little bit
risky especially with Bishop coming here
in some situations I guess for the
moment the knight on c4 Knight to c4 is
possible but her idea might have been to
actually take this follow it up with 95
a lot of threats coming in so taking
giving up the d5 squares too much I
agree with the rulers decision but here
she did something unexpected she played
b4 very aggressive and I thought for
sure her idea was to play 9 c4 the idea
being that rook comes to b4 and after
take stakes you're gonna collect this
this King's gonna be a little bit weak I
don't know I thought she had okay
chances here but instead she played a
knight a4 and after Bishop d4 Bishop d7
thought that simply took took and played
b3 and here it looked to me like Tata
was getting the upper hand the ruler
took this pawn back and maybe tots off
could have thought about the endgame in
taking this pawn but if she instead
decided to keep the Queen's on
and then played b4 again I thought that
Bishop to c4 was maybe another
possibility aiming these bishops look
quite strong to me maybe some point
Bishop back and queen here trying to
mate
it looks very uncomfortable for black
but in the game before was played and as
we can see the Queen went back Bishop c4
rook f1 and ster ruler of course has two
tries to attack keep in mind she needs
to win for the GM norm look at fate d5
and things are just getting completely
crazy so the idea is that Bishop takes
c6 is a huge threat if you take the
bishop I take this rook and there's lots
of threats also coming in the dark
squares are really bad this Bishop hangs
not exactly sure she tries to check
instead Bishop comes back Queen back t5
c3 so preventing this checkmates
Bishop hangs this Bishop hangs I
honestly do not have any clue what's
going on anymore it seems like both
sides don't have much time either
they're both under two minutes we're
gonna keep it we're gonna keep an eye on
this game but for now we have a guest in
the studio how's it going
so Brandon Jacobsen so you had kind of a
rough event but then you finished really
well
why don't you tell us about your event
yeah so starting the tournament I was
getting too crazy time pressure making
ridiculous lenders yeah so in the second
half of the tournament I tried to play a
lot faster and a bit more safe because
in these tactical positions I've just
been wondering so for example like this
last game yeah I paid a quick Queen
trade line against the Khan because I
figured that would be safest so
basically you went from playing a little
too slowly to playing quicker and trying
to have an emphasis on safety yeah
because I felt like in the beginning of
the tournament I wasted too much time
and like simple moves work I didn't have
enough time at the critical moments so I
was really trying to make sure I spent
more time where I need
okay so why don't you take us through
your game a little bit there was one
moment where I have these thoughts oh
you've traded in to a quick end game yes
it looks close to equal but nothing yeah
close to equal it's a little bit more
pleasant for white with so much just
because your pawn structure is a little
nicer black has this weakness yeah I
thought around here
probably black should actually just sit
because black has pretty good rooks this
Knight looks pretty strong yeah I wasn't
sure if you had a plan to make progress
here yeah that's what I'd thought he'd
do because I mean it was dead of a4
originally I wanted to try to put the
nigh on c5 somehow if I did it
immediately he would just go a5 and b6
and originally wanted to play v4 but
then then he can play the plan with the
Knight to c4
oh it's kind of unpleasant for me so
yeah here I thought you should just wait
because with what he did that allowed a
lot more chances for me on the Queen
side yeah it seemed like after this his
knight was actually worse on d6 though
yeah so you've got to double those one
perk and then c4 so I guess tactically
this just works for you yeah I figure
that's the only try have because if I
wait any longer black will probably
consolidate mm-hmm and so in this
position I mean he allowed c5 and I
wasn't sure exactly what was going on
does he have an alternative here like is
it possible to play c5 himself yeah so I
was looking at c5 not I probably have
two options I can do an eddy one or
night c1 mhm
if I see one maybe rook f8 and then if I
go F for there you can take twice on f4
and after I take the knight on d6 a
second so night c1 you can double on
that I can double f4 so f4 maybe not a
force move but F 4 takes takes takes you
grab this night but then the checks and
the problem is if you ever cross the
line was rings okay so this would
probably be draw yes okay so instead of
might see one sort of nice see what I'm
probably going that e1 91
yeah these positions are funny when you
have these puns because it's usually a
battle whoever gets the night in here
first or the knight and d4 first ends up
good I figured I didn't calculate
concrete lines but I figured because
when he moves tonight I wrote d7 oh so
I'll probably get to d5
makes sense the only problem I guess I
can see is that your king temporarily
blocks you seven probably matter of
seven okay so he would allow the rook in
yeah
rook here you can play that for now is
what you're saying yeah is it possible
to move back yeah I think I looked at
this but I think I can just go out five
here so just go five and yeah
these pawns are pretty annoying for sure
I can play g6 but maybe this g4 h 5 gets
respond to g5 I'd imagine yeah this
looks this looks pretty pretty nice for
you but in any case after Knight be 75
it looks just very nice the point is
that I thought black might try to take
it was probably transposes okay because
I put the rook on the C file and take go
okay so I thought after Knight takes
your plan was to take and play route d7
oh yeah and then king b6 I thought this
King was actually not great rook takes
g7 Brooke f8 I was looking at probably
black should try to activate with
something like this before I would
imagine five but somehow I think your
position should be good you're up too
many puns this this is weak so for
example if you take you can maybe go
here hitting this pawn it looks like if
a solution falls apart
I would agree so I thought for sure
almost for sure black would play pawn
takes here and what was your plan um
either rook c2 or I was also looking at
night Pete - yeah 92 I kind of like
honestly but I guess then the knight can
come to d6 probably rook see one just to
keep the rook on d2 defended if he moves
rook and I can take 95 now right so
there I guess rook FA it's possible King
b6 is possibly forgive a can take any
five right
oh is this true so the rook is basically
paralyzed as long as the knight is here
so probably the King has to move and now
maybe Knightly - because I see for a
college council check and if Knight back
I guess you can take but you're gonna
slick whaa dating rights
maybe I can take steaks 9c for King c7
take take in the kindy 3 or something
that might be unpleasant if it got in
King c4 of d1 so which would be 6
okay so route 66 takes and no king d3
maybe uh-huh so you're trying to get
into key c4 I guess black can play here
but you can always go here there's no
yeah thanking something to eat and then
I can go check and rook d3 two different
yeah maybe I can play like rook b8 at
some point to try to stop you and then
you have a four perhaps yeah no no it's
definitely better I would say and here I
thought you also had a possibilities
like even this and just saying you know
what your king is worse than mine
they have this I have this maybe just
came back in rooks v---aids
maybe it's not so simple but but I don't
know I mean it's a complicated ending
but it seemed like after b5 this night
um b7 was just too poor a piece I like
this before move as we were pointing out
earlier this check is quite annoying so
once this happened I thought that you
just were better because this Knight is
if he doesn't go in for that it's
probably too dangerous like it for
example if it takes on before and as
long as I can go see 6 years ah c6 so
you don't even take ok c6 so now if King
takes c6 that takes before that takes
before you're just getting waited here
wasn't it's always fun when you actually
get to checkmate in the end game so
let's see so king c5 perhaps mhm
so probably that d5 uh-huh so this King
is just so now the idea is now rook
check and then this night will move with
check and it's gonna be kind of nasty
yeah I I I mean maybe here look be
careful I think it's here maybe maybe
I'm okay maybe not 95 yeah I think I was
looking at a more forcing line oh I
don't matter cuz you can play 96 but
then I play King d6 it seems okay I
don't know if you have to play c6 though
no like I thought that maybe you can
just play Knight takes d5 rook comes in
with check I mean this looks ok
so I thought this might be a even
simpler but after a four it seemed like
you the tactics are just gonna work for
you blacks King and King c6 is just
basically losing after 92 you can't the
55 yeah I thought you might just play
Knight d4 but it probably a lot more
caramel 64 it yeah
probably it's all winnings felony I
liked what you did that doesn't go King
c6 it's not as easy dr. King c6 92 it's
basically just you know so after that
you won very easily but if me 98 here
it's 98 because Black has to fix this
Knight if you can get to c6 is actually
not about peace but the question is
whether you can do anything dynamic here
yeah that was a problem for black
because tonight 96 I was looking at 96
94 here because if 95 1595
can be 7 seems like I hold I see 3 then
rook fe 7 exactly yeah I don't really
have a continuation here it seems like
focus you don't want to give up this
pawn everything's defendant this does
hang although it often allows this yeah
I mean it still looks you definitely
slower you'd have to move your king
maybe defend this pawn so you wanted to
play 96 check I must play here and then
Knight d4 you said so you're just trying
to trade off this Knight once he takes
my changes a lot more out different I
have to fast upon yeah and it seems a
good speed pawns gonna be lost
yeah yeah so in the game it just was
fairly straightforward and yeah this
nighttime before got traps and yeah here
we were I think after here you can win
with c7 b6 but probably taking them yeah
it's all pretty good
so you actually so he was actually
playing for his know him I think he
already had three buds yeah he already
has his noreña
he's just playing for up but you ended
on a really high note so what was your
experience like yeah really great it was
a lot it was a lot more professional
than I needed other tournaments are
fleeting because I haven't really faded
many like closing door and tournaments
before any so yeah I really enjoyed it's
a good experience and I'd say you get
better in them as you play them like
round robins or tricky they're a little
bit different yeah it's not as forgiving
like you lose you don't play easier
people so probably a different
experience but this is but it's a nice
place to play when is your next event
the amateur came East and it starts on
Saturday so it'll be a bit more relaxed
yes I'd imagine
all right well best of luck in nuts and
thanks for coming on thank you
a moment comes in chess when you need to
test yourself at a different level chess
24 premium offers the tools that you
need to reach your maximum potential
from hundreds of interactive video
lessons to becoming part of the chess 24
community you can analyze with friends
or coach your students live you get
twenty four by seven coverage of chest
news and events access to premium
analysis and commentary and the chance
to interact with grandmasters and other
top players and coaches get it bashed
from the best and even challenged them
to a battle be the best chess player you
can be it's time to level up your game
with just 24 Premium Membership be
surprised be intrigued be delighted the
World Chess Hall of Fame in st. Louis is
nothing you'd expect and everything you
love
three galleries highlight the history
culture and creativity behind the game
explore chess in ways you never imagined
it's a one-of-a-kind cultural
institution where rare artifacts and
world-class art play together the world
chess Hall of Fame mind art experience
question on Twitter from dem s I should
not have pronounced that that was a bit
of a champion for those of you who are
new to chess it might look like VA 3 is
an illegal move here because white
advances pawn to squares not one but it
still is something we call a song and
you can do that you have to do it
instantly you can't wait for a move I
plant a play king in seven kimchi - and
I'll try because four against Lawrence
and now he's going to play something
against me which we discussed the
playing during the course of my steak
yeah he told me this is that g5 this was
what I was kind of hoping for because
now I think we practiced I know Lawrence
this is not how it works certainly would
be much much more fun attached to work
like this we don't think it does well
maybe it does well that's me
regretting what I just said how did I
get from there to here is a little bit
beyond me and what's worse I will never
hear the end of it my quality of life
has just gone downhill tremendously
because I'm actually sharing the office
with the guy
[Music]
you
[Music]
both okay hello and welcome back to the
st. Louis norm Congress broadcast it's
the final round but we're taking a break
to talk to one of the most important
personalities here around the st. Louis
chess campus I'm talking about
Development Manager Loren Stewart Loren
thanks for coming on the show thanks for
having me
awesome so you have one of the most
important jobs there is you basically do
fundraising for the chess campus tell us
about that
so we have so much going on here at the
chest campus that we need to make sure
that all of our programs are funded most
importantly our scholastic chess program
we're just taking chest into the schools
in st. Louis serving low-income students
and so we provide chess programming to
them and so we make sure that we bring
in enough dollars that can support that
program and what is it about the Chess
Club and the world chess Hall Fame I
guess we're talking more about the Chess
Club at this moment as a nonprofit that
separates it it's kind of unique from
other nonprofits right correct so you
know chess is a fun game and what we
found is that it's a really different
holistic way of teaching and that
teachers have really taken to it another
unique thing about it that's different
from other nonprofits educational
nonprofits that is is that we do a
research component so our research is
really showing that chess is giving kids
confidence to take on more difficult
tasks they want to be at school it's
giving them confidence just better
quality of life so we feel that that's a
really unique component and that that's
why all students should receive the game
and I know that the club has had some
great grants and partners with
corporations talk a little bit about
some of the companies were partnering
with sure so we have a lot of really
generous partners one is ascension an
ascension has really come through and
they fully support the Ferguson
flourescent School District and
providing chess to those schools so
we're really fortunate to have them and
just to have them as a really great
partner an ascension is a healthcare
company is that right the correct so
there are Catholic health care provider
and they are headquartered here in st.
Louis and have hospitals all over the
United States
so upcoming we have
the US Chess Championship correct in
just a couple of months so that's a
really big event can people get involved
with that in some way and help out sure
so with sponsorship opportunities we
have for the US Chess Championship it's
just a great way for companies to get
involved it really gets their name out
there it's a really broad reach really
international reach so we encourage
anybody that would like to support that
to support the Chess Championship
wonderful and the u.s. championship
always has so many eyes on it it's a the
traditionally the biggest event we've
had
although the Singh field that might be a
little bit bigger nowadays Lauren you've
been here since almost the beginning
like ten years why is it so awesome
working for the chess campus well I
think you know there's a couple
different reasons but I think you know
apart from the amazing programming that
we do here and serving as many students
that we do almost 30,000 since we opened
our doors I think that the staff is just
so incredible and I think that you know
everybody has their their talents and
our team just really works together well
sounds great thank you for coming on the
show if you appreciate it
let's take a break you're watching us
chess champs calm and coverage of the
st. Louis norm Congress we're coming
back with more analysis
[Music]
[Music]
you could fly to Venice
[Music]
or Paris
or even Copenhagen
you can fly all over the world why
when you could just come to st. Louis
your trip begins at explore st. Louis
calm a moment comes in chess when you
need to test yourself at a different
level chess 24 premium offers the tools
that you need to reach your maximum
potential from hundreds of interactive
video lessons to becoming part of the
chess 24 community you can analyze with
friends or coach your students live you
get twenty four by seven coverage of
chest news and events access to premium
analysis and commentary and the chance
to interact with grandmasters and other
top players and coaches get it bashed
from the best and even challenge them to
a battle be the best chess player you
can be it's time to level up your game
with just 24 Premium Membership all
right I'm
hello chess fans we got a commercial
play but it's good to see you back here
at the st. Louis norm Congress I'm Ben
Simon along with Grandmaster Josh free
del and and they chest 24 is talking
over us just 20 what are you doing chest
Wickliffe uh ddr1 check it all right
there we go
all right yeah we got it yeah you stay
in your place chest 24 know we love
chest 24 but Josh we did miss a few
things in coverage for this route what
are we looking at so first just to keep
you updated on results as we mentioned
gu Davis drew against Bartholomew in the
GM norm section mark perago beat Danish
boorish everyone else is still playing
the game I would like to focus on at the
moment is stuff Rula soloqueue
is black against Ottawa barhom Ian and
this was again as we mentioned our game
of the day and as we can see it's gotten
to an end game
scheme got completely knots neither side
has either time as any time and this is
kind of what happens so if we can bring
this position up there we go and at the
moment neither has either time and just
to show you how easy it is for one side
to make a big error here
if white black had chosen g3 for
instance it seems like black is on the
way to qui t'a however why does this
surprise in store
rook check King has to go somewhere
defending the bishop rook takes Bishop
with check get a queen with check check
with a nice memory but at first it looks
like black has a defense you can play
King f5 Bishop takes rook and King e4
cutting off this bishop and then it
looks like the pawn Queens however King
c3 just in time and white would indeed
win of course the ruler did not play
this she instead played Bishop h8 and
then tots have played rook a 5
g3 rook to g5 I actually thought that
the ruler would really rather not allow
this cut off maybe she didn't have a
choice again with no time it's so
difficult to play these positions
I thought maybe even King f6 or King f7
here maybe King f6 looks crazy allowing
this check but the idea is that now this
King is well placed you ready to take
this pawn it looks kind of dross to me
but she played g3 and after rook g5 rook
c7 so my guess would be that these pawns
will liquidate h7 and g3 and it should
be a draw with best play of course the
King is in front this pawn is probably
not good enough usually just one pawn to
win especially with lots of pieces still
on the board is not good enough I would
suspect it's gonna be something like
rook takes g3 rook takes it maybe she'll
try cutting off the King or something
but honestly this should be pretty
comfortably drawn which is actually not
a terrible result but at the same time
stavroula needed that win to score the
GM norm so she's probably not super
happy with developments at the same time
both of them having a pretty excellent
tournament ending on a draw
doesn't really spoil that no an amazing
turret actually and I already stabbed
ruler has clinched her international
master norm even though she's in the
gM norm section she got four and a half
points across that threshold so it
passed across two quite easily but I
would say performing it at I am norm is
actually pretty standard for that's only
for twenty four fifty forty points or
less than forty points above her actual
rating not I mean it's still a nice
performance it means she's playing well
but she's gonna get many many I am norms
and it's only a matter of time there but
a GM norm is pumping probably a little
farther away it's like you said like how
does she yeah before this tournament
it's it's quite a mystery I have to
admit I didn't care for the move she
just played King d5 I just don't like
walking into c4 and maybe it's just a
personal thing but I would get kind of
always paranoid about this but at the
same time it should be pretty
comfortably drawn maybe black and white
can try to be a little tricky and play a
move like rook g8 with the idea that
after takes you give a check and now at
least you get to play rook and Bishop
against rook maybe some chances although
after g2 it looks like this pawn is very
close but probably the bishop runs back
I don't know okay - probably this is
actually you're not even gonna get to
play it in fact if you're not careful
you might have to play King and Bishop
against king and rook she didn't in fact
play rook g8 so we'll see if this
happens we're gonna kind of stick with
this game just cuz neither side has any
time so Rula has less than 10 seconds
I'm guessing she's gonna snap off that
pawn you can see them on the monitor
there needless to say they don't look
like they're having a coffee and
chilling now these guys these girls are
completely focused and yeah I mean it's
still quite a tense game this may look
like a simple position to you but when
you have less than 10 seconds this is
quite brutal so she does indeed take
this pawn and I guess we're gonna see if
she plays c4 it doesn't look like it's
that simple but yep she plays c4 I
assume the palm will be captured yes it
is Bishop takes Bishop it's coming next
I believe by the way note how Luke takes
bishop would actually be a horrible
mistake because you trade the rooks g2
that is not fun then
that's it this guy is gonna queen so I
believe she will take with the bishop
and she did so this happened
King here our board actually is a little
bit behind but luckily when you can see
the players it becomes quite easy Bishop
takes h8 and here I'm not exactly sure
maybe she's gonna try rook check first
King here in g2 and it looks like it's
just gonna be a draw most likely because
you're gonna play king e1 probably and
now you could do anything you want you
could just take this bishop because if
you try to if you try to do something
else I think it's just gonna be just not
gonna work out I have to play yeah so
this happened rook h2 check I think it's
gonna be King d1 and they're gonna draw
will be my guess we'll wait for it to
occur King d1 G - indeed
and yeah I'm guessing King e1 and they
will shake hands who'll be my guess of
course I could miss something they could
miss something but this looks pretty
basic yeah because the problem is if you
move the bishop then I give a check and
queen and now you at least have to
defend rook against King and King and
Bishop against king and rook not that
that's very difficult but there's no
reason to make yourself suffer if you
don't have to thought that's still
thinking probably checking to see if she
has any last chance to win the game you
always do this even if you think it's
simple you never like to give up winning
a game and especially a game where you
really should have had your chances I
believe Tata was probably winning this
game earlier but sometimes it's
difficult to close out and it looks like
yeah she does indeed play King you won
and I believe they will shake hands very
shortly I don't know whether she'll play
g1 or take the bishop or play rook h1
you have a million ways to actually
secure the draw here and I'm only
slightly exaggerating so we'll see yeah
she took and then they agreed to it
so takes takes so we have a results
table ruler drawers as black against
Tata stuff ruler ends up with a really
really nice score temporarily tied for
the lead although of course if Verano of
wins his game or even draws his game he
will pass her and Adi Patel is still
playing as well so with a win he could
also pass her although it looks like Adi
is down a rook for a queen we can bring
up this game very quickly yeah so Adi is
in some trouble as white we talked about
fortresses earlier been with Queen
against rook but this one is not even
close there are way too many pawns still
left on the board black has a pawn here
probably something like Queen check this
Kings almost paralyzed I would say that
this is just a matter of a few moves
before black should win which means that
actually
stavroula is tied for the lead with
pavlova also if if it did Adi does lose
and it's all up to parantha if he scores
at all then he clinches the field
indeed so he only needs to draw this
game he is up upon and know losing
chances at all this is a good game to
draw although I'm pretty sure and guys
so you guys know like a lot of people
ask like well do you just offer a draw
in a position like this if your if it
clinches the whole tournament a couple
players will but I would say most
winning is always the goal of a chess
game like you'd rather win than draw so
if there's no risk especially why not
play on of course you have to be a
little careful if you allow rookie three
g4 and can opt F for you of some losing
chances but honestly there's no way he's
gonna just want to draw here he played
the move c4 so the threat here of course
is pawn takes pawn followed by trading
rooks which would be an easy win Oxshott
plays rook III oxide has under a minute
which is fairly typical but to be fair
it's past its past 660 move 60 it's not
move 63 so it's quite typical so rookie
3 the idea of course is that if the King
goes back this King goes up this is
hanging but my guess would be he will
capture on d5 and the idea being that
apon takes you play rook here and you're
threatening to come up like this one
possible
I would be g4 here rook takes pawn shot
King here and this actually looks like
it might draw because if you play rook
check trading him to trade off the rooks
I take this pawn I'm just in time King
takes pawn King takes King walks over
fairly simple draw so he's actually
gonna have to find an improvement on
that line if he wants to win this game
that being said I think he'll be able to
do it one option is maybe pawn takes
pawn followed by King f2 an idea now is
if you play King F for defending your
rook not only do you get checked this is
in fact checkmate oh my goodness it's
amazing
that is pretty cool yeah so do be
careful checkmate does exist in the
endgame however after the rook moves
over here I'm not exactly sure what's
going on it's a very strange position it
seems like this you're gonna get away
with taking this pawn because playing a
move like this is simply too passive the
King goes up at the moment I'm not
exactly seeing what the plan is here
after rook e3 my guess would be he's
gonna try to keep it more double it so
he's probably just gonna take this pawn
what am I talking about cuz yeah now if
I guess now g4 is still possible but
honestly this is a lot of pawns so if
you play g4 maybe I'm just gonna let you
have this one and just start taking and
pushing so for example just pawn takes
pawn rook check ah but this guy hangs
yeah I can't allow that trying to get
acclimated here umm yeah I don't see a
real easy way to do this because the
problem is you take on c6 you're always
have b3 hanging kicking the D pawn only
gives you doubled pawns as we've seen
this is still gonna be a complicated
game you can see that Virant saw is
probably a little disappointed here
because i think he was up at pawn
earlier very comfortably like rook
ending up on no counter play whatsoever
but this is credit to auction Oxshott is
having a disasters tournament but this
is the feature of strong players no
matter how bad their tournament is
they're always dangerous they can always
find resources and even though you know
Oxshott is maybe still gonna lose this
game he's still fighting and still
looking for the best ways to go to try
to save it and it's a good sign so he
doesn't
take on d5 aux Agra captures so the
question is whether you have anything
here move like king F - I like that
first but after rook d3 it seems like
just too active and again in the real
Ken games this is maybe one of the most
common key features that active rook
active King if you have both of those
things active even if you're down upon
you can often save the draw whereas I've
seen plenty of rook any and you're not
even down material but if you have
passive rook passive king it's often
terrible so note that even though our
shots down upon he does have that so he
does play rook e8 g4 was played this is
the line we looked at if ruk takes pawn
now King here you just can't trade those
rooks it seems like that endgame is
simply a draw so you'd have to move the
rook somewhere something like this but
honestly I'd say the odds of that
winning this are almost nothing you play
pawn takes pawn
for example if King f2 you go here just
a dead drop there's no way you can win
this and in fact King e6 did occur but
it's possible that Veron Civ already
knows that a draw will clinch him first
so he's not looking quite as hard that's
one of the things especially if you have
no time if you know what draw coaches
you first you still might want to win
but you're not gonna take crazy risks
there's no point especially you know to
get someone like I've shown good indeed
and I would say that it's just one of
those things that when you're playing an
event you're always trying to win but
the results of the tournament does kind
of take priority so if you have just a
no risk position like we were talking
about of course you play there's no
reason not to play but if there's any
risk at all that's when it's like
alright make the draw
make sure you cinch that tournament
maybe he hasn't seen the game with a D
and we can already see that a D did in
fact lose after Queen h3 as a similar to
the lines we were pointing out whites in
looks long if you play here you simply
give away your pawn anywhere the rook
moves you take this the King can't move
without giving away the rook so a very
typical zoogs long position and a d does
go down so it looks like parantha will
win clear with stuff Rula as ii and yep
and this is happening takes on e5 pawn
takes yeah I'm pretty sure they're just
gonna draw
and yeah okay we're gonna see it right
now
so Pavlova runts of winds the GM normal
section as mentioned earlier I am NOT
single one the I am room section
yesterday he already clinched it with
around despair but this one was really
down to the wire and it went down to
this game so yeah they clearly have
drawn so good defense by Oakshott he was
down upon he had a miserable position
all game but he held in he kind of held
on and really was able to do it so
congratulations to Pablo why don't we
check out some other games so all of the
important stuff is over at this point it
does see we're gonna see if we can talk
to some of these players and yeah let's
take a look at what else is going on so
just to keep you up to speed so Matt
Cinco actually drew against Justin wing
12 year-old Justin Wayne holds much
saenko to a draw you could argue that
Matt's ankle already cleaved clear first
he was like whatever I guarantee you he
did not want to draw this game he was up
upon in fact in this position yet he's
up to ponds that are connected but quite
clearly opposite fisherman game Justin
can just sit forever and held the draw
against the highest rated player in both
tournaments so well done to justin wing
well from Katy Texas Justin wait yeah
what if he if he comes back for these
tournaments he's gonna be one of our
favorite players he's a good interview
he's he's he's just a funny dude I like
him yeah I haven't actually talked to
Justin much but I've played it in many
tournaments he is intense if I could be
that intense when I'm playing chess I'd
probably be a little stronger in any
case we do have some game still going
Joe bonala beat Chiyu who lost and is in
clear last place tough event for her she
still had some chances in some of her
games but not Suzy and Joel kind of had
a up-and-down event but he gets a nice
win in the last round so that was nice
for him as mentioned Brendon Jacobson
already beat Josh koulos we do have a
game between
Luis Torres and Josiah Stearman and this
one is kind of a mess bent
it looked like white was up in exchange
it looked like he was on his way to
victory but they got to a position let
me kind of go around to where I saw it
it was like here and it's one of those
positions where even though whites up in
exchange honestly it's so much easier to
play for black because as white it's
just everything's tied down you have
this rook which isn't really obviously
more useful and you have all these
weaknesses and even if objectively it
should be drawn sometimes these
positions are much harder to play for
the side with the rook compared to the
side with the bishop you have to hold on
to all these pawns at all times and your
King is weaker just one of those
positions and it seems like Josiah did
in fact get the better of them so they
danced around a little bit and he just
gives away this pawn I'm wondering if
this was actually necessary because it
seems like he should be able to hold on
to it I don't I don't see why that's
necessary even if you play like I move
like Queen d3 for example maybe there's
a check here but I'm not so sure that
this is truly the ends of the earth also
I mean maybe the King can just keep
moving maybe he was really trying to
push for the win in either case it seems
like this might just be a blunder
because once you lose this pawn you lose
the a3 pawn my guess is he just had no
time and it's unfortunate but these
things do happen and yeah now Josiah
should be in pretty good shape I would
have no sighting score sheets now yeah
so it seems like Josiah did win yeah
got to this position and it's an endgame
you still have your rook but you're
gonna lose this pawn this pawn is up
this is just way too many pawns and
eventually they just keep rolling down
the board so Josiah gets a nice last run
win Torres who was one of our early
leaders really suffered a lot of
setbacks lost a few games and then lost
this last one so kind of a tough finish
for him but at the same time you know
plenty of plenty to do next event and
Josh we have the entire field for the
Grandmaster norm section all cleared up
let's take a look at the standings and
actually we can tell you the prize
breakdown as well once again there are
no grandmaster norms although Seoul
Aikido and Abraham Ian have achieved
international master norms with the
first place is Pablo over
so he wins $2,000 second place is
stavroula soul aikido with $1,500 and
then we have a four-way tie for third
place
so those prizes will be combined and as
I'm doing the math right now in my head
I think it's somewhere like 1,800 700
600 divided by 4 okay all the way down
but we'll do that later
so those are the final standings
congratulations to Pablo for Anza we're
going to have him on here in just a
moment Josh yep should be good to talk
to him and as we see it's the ruler
clear second great result but just
missing on the gym norm fuge pack of
chasing it at third place indeed okay we
will be back in just about 30 seconds
with our next interview a moment comes
in chess when you need to test yourself
at a different level chess 24 premium
offers the tools that you need to reach
your maximum potential from hundreds of
interactive video lessons to becoming
part of the chess 24 community you can
analyze with friends or coach your
students live you get twenty four by
seven coverage of chess news and events
access to premium analysis and
commentary and the chance to interact
with grandmasters and other top players
and coaches get it bashed from the best
and even challenged them to a battle be
the best chess player you can be it's
time to level up your game with chess 24
Premium Membership I'm Mike Matheny
whether you play chess for fun or want
to boost your child's academic
performance come visit the Chess Club
and scholastic center of st. Louis right
here in the chest capital of the u.s.
from a welcoming diverse environment to
a Scholastic outreach program now in
over 100 schools our Center across from
the World Chess Hall of Fame's
has it all so whether you've played for
years or never before we invite you to
experience all chess has to offer
[Music]
you could fly to Venice
[Music]
or Paris or even Copenhagen
you could fly all over the world but why
when you could just come to st. Louis
your trip begins at explore st. Louis
calm
welcome back everyone I'm with the
winner of the GM norm section Pablo
Vorontsov congratulations thank you uh
why don't you take us through your last
round game with Oksana yeah
the opening was nothing special just
regular auntie Berlin I took on e5 just
wanted to play safe in the West wrong
because I was leading by half a point I
think so I decided to play this one 95
rookie five castles 93 this is all just
theory mighty 95 so the point of this
line is to take the bishop on stage and
try to play for a slight advantage c6 93
yeah it looks it's kind of hard to
explain this line because basically you
hop this night around a bunch of times
just to take a bishop that's not
developed but the hope is that in the
long term you play slowly the bishops
rule yes something and also work as an
option of Bishop e7 which is slightly
sharper Lionel yes si 497 yeah you
should be poor and it's probably gonna
equalize as well yeah the idea is just
with c4 that if you allow d5 is black
it's just very easy play so you play a
move like c4 it looks a little strange
but you're just trying to make this so
after 97 you were saying d4 d5 CD you
shouldn't be for aha
so why is this move important because
the bishop on a stone is so like for
example if I play pawn takes pawn mm a
little bit more awkward maybe Bishop d3
comes out so yeah but I think before
before is it sufficient before this
pyramid so make sure this bishop doesn't
hang you're trading off kind of the
bishops you don't want to technically
but probably not such a big deal 1995 25
rookie fight and then Bishop to c4 so
Queen here probably 26 Bishop c4 and
black is trying to exchange the rooks I
want the e-file and so black well maybe
try something like this yeah and again
white is isolated pawn but White's al
also a lot more active so it seems a
little unpleasant for black but maybe
holding
he chose Bishop c7 which also is I'm
sure totally fine but you do snag this
bishop so at least you get something to
play for in a long-term and again it's
kind of what you want right fairly safe
yeah nothing too interesting but you
still want to play because you don't
know if you're gonna happen to win yeah
so do you three three f5 was not sure
that if I was a great move here but
maybe this was the first slight mistake
no I I didn't really remember like what
is the main move here for black I just I
just knew what's going on into position
White has to be first and that's why the
plantation workers to exchange
everything so yeah some positions it's
like if you don't know all the concrete
ideas it's not as big a deal just
because it's fairly safe and you can
usually figure things out over the board
I have seen this up five idea before and
I believe the idea is that this Bishop
temporarily is not great and this is
basically to almost discourage this
bishop from getting out somehow but
honestly yeah I mean it looked like in
the game at least it did not really work
out well so Queen f3 Queen f3 Queen f6
huh CC 396 bishop of for this is an
illogical and figure of course work has
to play Knight of sound because if they
play rook F or C to eight doesn't matter
White has an option of Queen g3 and this
being a wonder h2 + v HT to be diagonal
is very important so 94 7 is forced yeah
but after night of 7 it seemed like you
maintain control over the e-file on that
yeah unpleasant here I was also
considering Bishop is 7 Lucas own Andrew
get and Bishop the sound rookie sound
rookie - or maybe Queen f4 but you
really this looks a little simpler yeah
anything special there so takes JP
eights
yeah and the problem is as long as you
control this file it's always a little
bit unpleasant and again it's kind of a
perfect position for you for this game
because you have no risk and you get to
still play yes so this was a founder
yeah so queen e3 and of course the idea
is hit this pawn queen e8 is mate so
you'd rather blunder the pond
obviously but yeah this is I'd say a
pretty healthy palm because you come
back you develop so a four is natural
move here try to create some comfort
please usually weak afraid Bishop III so
first I think in here yeah I had several
options to chose to simplify right yes I
just wanted to play safer maybe maybe
the service is not a strongest move and
I felt like it's not the strongest move
because I I saw some Lions starting with
rooky sticks or queen b7 as an option as
well
95 maybe Queen d7 but then maybe
something like h5
yeah I'd imagine you can try taking this
Oh 95 95 Bishop g4 possible
maybe you should you for yeah but the
tricky thing is when you're actually
playing this game in you're trying to
compete with first place like you have
to allow this and you know if you can
play it safe and have zero losing
chances it's a very understandable thing
my guess would be somehow this should be
good for you right yeah I think so you
know without a computer sitting next to
it's a little trickier so you decided to
just take away this night takeaway
chances and honestly it should be good
enough for a women oh man yeah I think
so
so just a healthy extra point so a very
understandable decision queen g4
centralizing made sense h6 queen e3 so
yeah I thought at some point you might
just try advancing but um I guess
there's no rush but yeah just I just
wanted to make sure you yeah again
sometime gain control over the e-file d4
that was actually a little surprised by
d4 I thought you might just leave it on
d3 but I mean yeah but III thought for
instance if I played kimchi too then it
has an option of d4 25 because you can't
take a yeah yeah and okay it's 94 then I
yeah
divorce maybe so Queen a 5 Kim G - Queen
B 1 a 3 so yeah I mean you're up upon
but you need a clear plan it's not super
easy it seems like yeah the main idea is
of course to play something like rookie
3 or okay 5 Queen e2 and
threatened something like rookie six
maybe maybe trade rooks only eight so
you play here so you're trying to
basically reverse the order here and get
a rook in makes a lot of sense
h5 is good more thing because he has to
create some comfortably otherwise
can you try something like Queen g5 are
you worried about this guy Queen g5
Queen c2 and Queen c2 and yeah there's
no I mean you can go back to you three
if it's yeah now this is a little bit
annoying yeah so Queen III you played h4
and again a lot of the times when you're
down mature you just want to make the
game a little less stable so this idea
makes sense so you play at your five
five six and g4 would be a great move
here but doesn't work because of h3 can
h2 in a row 32 so just to illustrate for
you guys here runs into this and the
Queen all the rocking so keen h2 enroute
captain aha and then of course it's okay
it's not so good so g4 is not possible
so you have to take yeah I think they
have to yeah maybe I don't have to but
anyway he will take on g3 yeah so you
take take and now rock up to the threat
so you play f3 yeah but it already seems
a little bit more difficult than before
you you have an open King now
so Queen went back to h6 Queeny Queeny v
look up six six checks back
and then traded so the trades pretty
much forced here it seems like and you
get to this row cadmium which again I
thought should probably be winning but
you need still needs stall kind of
tricky yeah way to make progress I
thought you might try rookie five-year
rookie five it's a perfect move but what
can play route catch a rookie to it so
now this is a yeah and I don't have time
for Lucas Allen have to play King g2 and
then just kin f6 so I don't so you don't
actually get in mm-hmm makes a lot of
sense yeah I guess it doesn't really
work so you played back King f6 rook h5
and just repeating - game time I'm
assuming a four yeah I guess eventually
you have to push something yeah this is
wrong with possible points because I
yeah so King f5 the only problem is I
guess sometimes b5 will become or play
in some positions maybe not immediately
because you bring go behind but yeah
it's always something to look out for
the black just sits comes back so you
fix the pawns so now you're trying to
play with a six looks all reasonable
here but the problem is in the game at
least this counter play yeah for
instance if I play c4 then ideas with a
new cage for always work harder cage for
immediately yeah that was annoying so is
it possible to maybe come from behind or
maybe maybe c4 cage for obesity 425 so
he before he has to take home so he has
to take one person who page for rock
edge for yeah it seems like things are
liquidating a bit so probably you'd have
to take me yeah but then it's just to
draw King here and the problem is this
king is just you know too passive
difficult to win so yeah so you tried
yeah I thought you might try it like
group coming behind him but I guess
rookie six is still possible maybe
mm-hmm doesn't really
doesn't really achieve too much but but
yeah here it seems was kind of tough
here rookie three ie didn't find
anything for you here I looked at it
very briefly but it seems like
everything kind of works out there's a
thread of here if the key moves back
there's king out for and there's just no
time to take everything like after takes
I think probably just g4 right yeah you
took I need my first in plate here but
the problem is King and pawn endgame is
not a win so you know but you know I'm
not a terrible game it seems like you
probably would have liked to win but at
the same time you still clinch
tournament victory very nice tournament
have you played at the club before no I
haven't so this was actually a very nice
experience I liked it a lot and would
like to thank organizers for inviting me
Richard pointer Tony Ridge and it was it
was perfect I liked it a lot so
currently you're in Lubbock going to
this tech how's that been for you pretty
good I'm majoring in computer science
playing for the Texas Tech chess team
currently I am a sophomore there so
still have two years to go okay well
sounds like you think so
now you get to go back with a couple
thousand dollars to hopefully spend on
books or something okay okay what
happens tomorrow
classes tomorrow wow so going back and
already back to work well
congratulations again and thanks for
coming on thank you thank you so much
so we'll be right back
a moment comes in chess when you need to
test yourself at a different level chess
24 premium offers the tools that you
need to reach your maximum potential
from hundreds of interactive video
lessons to becoming part of the chess 24
community you can analyze with friends
or coach your students live you get
twenty four by seven coverage of chess
news and events access to premium
analysis and commentary and the chance
to interact with grandmasters and other
top players and coaches get advised from
the best and even challenge them to a
battle be the best chess player you can
be it's time to level up your game with
just 24 premium membership
[Music]
there's a weekend vacation in a nearby
city I'm Mike Metheny well you play
chess for fun or want to boost your
child's academic performance come visit
the Chess Club and scholastic center of
st. Louis right here in the chess
capital of the u.s. from a welcoming
diverse environment to a Scholastic
outreach program now in over 100 schools
our Center across from the world chess
Hall of Fame the Central West End has it
all so whether you've played for years
or never before we invite you to
experience all chess has to offer
[Music]
professional suites are from dem s I
should not have pronounced that that was
a bit of a champion
for those of you who are new to chess it
might look like VA 3 is an illegal move
here because white advances pawn two
squares or one but it still is something
we call hustle and you can do that but
you have to do it instantly you can't
wait for a move like let's say play King
in seven Kim G - and now try because all
play for against Lawrence and now he's
going to play something against me which
we discussed the playing during the
course of my stay
yeah he told me this is that d5 this was
what I was kind of hoping for because
now I think we practiced I know Lawrence
this is not how chess works certainly
would be much much more fun if chess
actually work like this I don't think it
does well maybe it does well that's me
regretting what I just said how did I
get from there to here is a little bit
beyond me
and what's worse I will never hear the
end of it my quality of life has just
gone downhill tremendously because I'm
actually sharing the office with the guy
[Music]
you
[Music]
welcome back to the final day report
from the 2018 st. Louis norm Congress
I'm Ben Simon with Grandmaster Josh
Friedel at my side we're just the
happiest team ever talking to the
champion Pablo Carranza who was just in
here and the event has concluded we just
saw during the break Tan's el turgut
with a victory over Aaron Grove in ski
and so we know that everything is
finished Josh indeed and let's take a
look at how things kind of stuff indeed
in the International master norm field
we had no norms but the players still
walk away with prize money so in tenth
place geojo with $400 ninth place feed a
master brandon Jacobson $400 he'll walk
away with international master Louise
Torres with four points $400
Aaron gourbin ski $400 Justin way $400
I'm sensing a pattern yeah and now and
now they start to escalate here now we
have a four-way tie for second place and
I can tell you that joel manawa josiah
Stearman tangel turgut and josh colas
will all walk away with $700
accommodation and average of those
prizes and then our champion of the
International master norm field is
international masters Sergey mat Sanko
who scored 7 points did as he was
expected to do and he will walk away
with $1,200 so congratulations to Sergei
and he certainly did 709 an event like
even if you're the highest rated by that
much it's still pleasant feeling to know
you know what I was the highest rated
for a reason he had some up-and-down
games it was not that smooth him an
affair I would say if you asked him
about his play he probably up and down
but he still got seven out of nine still
came over to victory probably he'll be
happy with that and again no one else I
like a lot of other really good
performances but no one quite steady
enough and consistent enough to
to that norm score of six right and it
yeah like we said it's very onset of
this thing it's not a sure thing that
someone's gonna walk away with a norm
and by the way we want you to know that
we did ask Sergey if he would like to be
interviewed and he politely declined so
we're not sliding him in any way so
let's take a look at the big section and
how they all finished up it's the
Grandmaster norm section now there were
no grandmaster norms achieved here
although stavroula stole Aikido and
taunted Abraham Ian did achieve
international Master norms for Tata of
it's useless four-step ruler though it's
not useless no somehow at 24 12 she
doesn't have all her norms in fact
apparently she doesn't have one I find
it a little confusing but I think it's
partially because she's a young player
she was benefiting from the 40k feat a
rule which means that she gains lots of
points in feed eight tournaments so I
think she's new to this rating and
honestly if she continues to play the
way she is she's gonna rack up norms at
almost every event I don't think she's
too concerned but it's always nice to
have that in your pocket she was half a
point shy of a GM norm almost there as
we see verano of played well came away
with the tournament victory he still had
two losses I still wasn't up and down
affair but he still he managed just
slightly to be more steady than his
competitors the players this field had a
combined $9,000 prize fund tied for
ninth place not the best performance
from them but they'll be back
grandmasters Akshat Chandra and Danish
barouche have $600 International Master
Daniel Gurevich 600 Taunton Barbara
Jaime and 600 John Bartholomew and Adi
Patel hammer cool off and Mark Parag WA
will walk away with the seven hundred
and seventy-five dollars split each
between them and then second place clear
stab rule Ursula key do with five and a
half points has $1,500 to her credit and
then our champion of the grand master
norm section grandmaster pavel over on
sub from ukraine he has scored six
points and walks away with $2,000 right
on back to Lubbock Texas
indeed and I'm sure
find that it comes in handy try not to
buy books though I'm telling you there's
a biggest scam out there yeah I
shouldn't have given him that advice but
I'm pretty sure the way he was looking
at me he was like I'm not gonna do that
yeah we're probably safe but it was a
fun tournament lots of people like lots
of crazy results I didn't feel like you
could predict any of them really
I thought the underdogs for the most
part performed really well especially in
the GM norm section between Steve rule
and thought so they both far
outperformed their ratings so that was
the story of the event yeah absolutely
and really like just a lot of fun to
watch every game was crazy there was not
a lot of you know a lot of the times the
one downside to round robins is that you
have games which are just you know a lot
of safe draws because people really are
trying not to lose they're trying to
play it safe as we saw this tournament
very few games actually went like that
and it was nice to see it was just a
really fun event to watch and to comment
on indeed and from the onset this was a
new venture that we had been trying this
is the first time that Josh and I have
done commentary before and there has
been a lot of firsts to this event we're
learning we're building we're growing
and we hope to bring you more events
throughout 2018 just like this including
just next month we have the spring at
chess classic one of our quarterly
tournaments so we'll be taking a look at
that in just about a month but thank you
for joining us it's been a really fun
time and this broadcast this whole event
has been produced by the world's
greatest production B team Tammy Hyatt
is the technical advisor Issac shruts is
audio and graphics Danny Machuca is our
technical director and here we are
Grand Master Josh free del and Ben Simon
saying thank you for joining us and we
will see you for the spring chess
classic on March 6 right here at us
chess champs dot-com but until then so
long from the Show Me State
[Music]
you